well effective advertising is
advertising that changes the behavior of
the consumer for one thing and also
effective advertising is advertising
that makes people feel a certain way
about a brand I mean it's all about the
brand and how people allow that brand to
influence their lives effective
advertising is there's lots of ways to
measure advertising these days you know
we do a lot of testing and we do a lot
of marketing research and things like
that but the overview of what makes an a
defective is do people remember it are
they motivated by it is it do the does
it help them feel a certain way about
the product or the brand that you're
trying to advertise its really I know
I've dumb that down but that's you know
kind of the bottom line of what we're
trying to do with effective advertising
that's why what's happening now in
advertising is kind of interesting you
know how how much has become a consumer
the content is so consumer driven it's
kind of interesting about you know how
you maintain the stewardship of a brand
when somebody everybody's doing so much
of their own kind of advertising
you